- [Instructor] So we have a
question here on p-values.
It says Evie read an article that said 6%
of teenagers were vegetarians,
but she thinks it's higher
for students at her school.
To test her theory, Evie
took a random sample
of 25 students at her school,
and 20% of them were vegetarians.
So just from this first paragraph,
some interesting things are being said.
It's saying that the true
population proportion,
if we believe this article, of teenagers
that are vegetarian,
we could say that is 6%.
Now for her school, there
is a null hypothesis
that the proportion of
students at her school
that are vegetarian, so
this is at her school,
that the true proportion,
the null would be as
the same as the proportion
of teenagers as a whole.
So that would be the null hypothesis.
And you can see that she's generating
an alternative hypothesis,
but she thinks it's higher for
students at her large school.
So her alternative hypothesis
would be the proportion,
the true population
parameter for her school
is greater than 6%.
And so to see whether
or not you could reject
the null hypothesis, you take a sample,
and that's exactly what Evie did.
She took a random sample of 25 students,
and you calculate the sample proportion.
And then you figure out
what is the probability
of getting a sample proportion
this high or greater?
And if it's lower than a threshold,
then you will reject your null hypothesis.
And that probability we call the p-value.
The p-value is equal to
the probability that
your sample proportion,
as she's doing this for
students at her school,
is going to be greater
than or equal to 20%
if you assumed that your
null hypothesis was true.
So if you assumed that the true proportion
at your school was 6% vegetarians,
but you took a sample of 25 students
where you got 20%, what is the probability
of getting 20% or greater
for a sample of 25?
Now there's many ways to approach it
but it looks like she
is using a simulation.
To see how likely a sample like this
was to happen by random chance alone,
Evie performed a simulation.
She simulated 40 samples
of n equals 25 students
from a large population where 6%
of the students were vegetarian.
She recorded the proportion
of vegetarians in each sample.
Here are the sample proportions
from her 40 samples.
So what she's doing here
with the simulation,
this is an approximation of
the sampling distribution
of the sample proportions
if you were to assume
that your null hypothesis is true.
And it says below,
Evie wants to test her null hypothesis
which is that the true
proportion at her school is 6%
versus the alternative hypothesis
that the true proportion at
her school is greater than 6%
where p is the true proportion of students
who are vegetarian at her school.
And then they ask us,
based on these simulated results,
what is the approximate
p-value of the test?
And they say, the sample result,
the sample proportion here, was 20%,
we saw that right over here.
Well if we assumed that this
is a reasonably good approximation
of our sampling distribution
of our sample proportions,
there's 40 data points here,
and how many of these samples
do we get a sample proportion
that is greater than or equal to 20%?
Well you could see this
is 20% right over here,
20 hundredths, and so
you see we have three
right over here that meet this constraint.
And so that is three out of 40.
So if we think this is a
reasonably good approximation,
we would say that our p-value
is going to be approximately
three out of 40, that
if the true population
proportion for the school were 6%,
if the null hypothesis were true,
then approximately three
out of every 40 times
you would expect to get a sample
with 20% or larger being vegetarians.
And so three-fortieths is what?
Let's see, if I multiply
both the numerator
and denominator by two and a half,
this is approximately equal to,
I say two and a half 'cause
to go from 40 to 100,
and then two and a half
times three would be 7.5.
So would say this is approximately 7.5%
and this is actually a
multiple choice question
and if we scroll down,
we do indeed see
approximately 7.5% right over there.